bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec kathia gilder rougeau katia bonjour
ni quelle est cette semaine dans
l'actualité les sénateurs font de la
résistance le texte sur le non cumul des
mandats
tel que le voulait le gouvernement a été
votée mais largement modifié les
parlementaires de la chambre haute ont
fait adopter un amendement qui leur
permet de créer une exception
sénatoriales et on verra sur la phrase
de la semaine le positionnement de
françois fillon sur le front national un
communiqué commun de l'ump a mis fin à
la collective à la polémique mais
l'incident est il vraiment clos le plus
de l'hebdo vous fera découvrir cette
semaine si vous ne le connaissez pas
encore la série du moment sur canal+
elle nous vient des états unis
house of cards l'univers impitoyable de
la politique américaine
on en parlera avec notre invité à la fin
de cette émission est notre invité cette
semaine valérie pécresse bonjour merci
d'être avec nous pour cette première
émission de la nouvelle saison de
parlement hebdo ancien ministre député
ump des yvelines secrétaire général
délégué du parti et présidente du groupe
ump au conseil régional d'île de france
voulez vous vraiment sortir de la crise
c'est le livre que vous sortez aux
éditions albin michel on en parle
beaucoup à la fois un bilan du
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy est
beaucoup beaucoup de propositions de
réformes tout un programme vous dit
beaucoup de choses ni la droite ni la
gauche n'ont eu le courage d'engager les
vraies réformes et vous appeler les
français à consentir à des sacrifices
alors il ya beaucoup de propositions
dans ce livre si vous deviez en retenir
une seule qui seraient prioritaires à
mettre en oeuvre demain quelle
serait-elle
voilà une seule c'est difficile puisque
mais en réalité ce urgente
non mais la 3d une philosophie derrière
le livre c'est qu'il va falloir
travailler davantage collectivement
dépenser moins et en même temps que le
travail paye et je crois que ça ça
résume assez bien le livre alors ça se
traduit comment concrètement par exemple
par le retour aux 39 heures dans la
fonction publique mais avec un gain
salariale conséquent ça se traduit par
l'assouplissement des 35 heures dans le
secteur privé avec le choix pour les
entreprises du temps de travail mais il
ya des propositions aussi sur la réforme
du bac sur la fusion département région
qui sont absolument cruciale si on veut
vraiment faire des économies pécresse il
ya beaucoup de propositions mais ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est un inventaire
de tout ce que vous n'avez pas pu faire
quand vous étiez au gouvernement
l'inventaire il est nécessaire et il est
utile parce que qu'est-ce qui se passe
et bien quand je croise des français
dans la rue ils me disent maintenant
vous vous opposez on a compris à
françois hollande mais qu'est ce que
vous proposez puis dès que je propose
quelque chose alors que ce soit sur
l'école la formation professionnelle
l'environnement on me dit mais pourquoi
vous l'avez pas fait avant vous avez été
au pouvoir disant pourquoi vous l'avez
pas fait donc il faut faire cet
inventaire non pas pour chercher des
responsables mais pour identifier les
causes des blocages la société française
même aventure que veut jean françois
copé ou pas à l'écouté je ne sais pas en
tout cas c'est c'est un travail très
très réfléchi très serein mon objectif
c'est pas je vous dis de faire de l'auto
flagellation mon objectif c'est de
débloquer la france de débloquer de
trouver les leviers de réformes il ya
des choses qu'on a réussi
on a tenu face à la rue sur l'université
on a repoussé l'âge de départ à la
retraite auxquels des choses qu'on a
faites qui sont formidables il ya des
endroits où on a calé vous dites quand
même pas car vous avez dû plier édulcoré
repousser certaines réformes
parce que finalement la la france a du
mal à se réformer c'est quoi les
blocages jeu qui paralyse c'est quoi les
blocages il ya la rue la violence
paralysante et j'essaye de raconter dans
le livre ce que c'est que de faire une
réforme de l'université avec neuf mois
de blocage 170 évacuation de fac
le spectre de malik oussékine et du
risque d'un accident qui fait peur qui
est on a vécu tout le quinquennat sous
la menace de la rue contrairement à ce
qui a été dit en réalité sur toutes les
réformes sociales
on vivait sous cette menace donc on a
reculé on a recruté sur le lit c'est
qu'on n'a pas réussi à faire donc la rue
le dialogue social
je raconte si les coulisses du dialogue
social comment on est dans un jeu de
rôle comment les partenaires sociaux
n'assume pas forcément leur rôle de
réussir des réformes oui alors il ya
aussi ce sujet et c'est aussi
l'inde est l'un dès lundi l'un des
sujets majeurs la france silencieuse la
france silencieuse celle qui convaincu
qu'il faut fusionner parler aujourd'hui
de payer
je leur demande de s'exprimer les
réseaux sociaux c'est fait pour ça
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on est on lance
des mouvements des débats d'idées
c'est l'année des propositions pour
l'ump 2013 et puis enfin il ya un sujet
c'est jaillir notre mythe de la réforme
cathédrale et ça c'est quelque chose
très important nous sommes le pays des
cartes on veut une réforme où il ya tout
dedans et la réforme il ya tout dedans
ça marche pas parce que la réforme en
fait c'est un élastique vous tirer sur
l'élastique et il faut surtout le tir et
le plus loin possible sans qu'il vous
éclater à la figure
voilà donc il faut jamais les trolls ont
parlé de l'ump je vous parle évidemment
de ce début de semaine où il ya une
comme une léger légère poussée de fièvre
pour votre partir dans vient tout de
suite mais d'abord les faits évidemment
le parti se déchirent sur l'attitude à
adopter face au front national après les
propos notamment de françois fillon une
nouvelle crise sur fond de bataille des
chefs présumés de germer andrieu il aura
fallu près de dix jours à françois
fillon pour s'expliquer à la sortie du
comité stratégique de l'ump l'ancien
premier ministre va disparaître toute
ambiguïté j'ai expliqué à mes amis
politiques que j'avais combattu le front
national toute ma vie et qu'ils
n'avaient pas l'intention de changer de
position que j'avais toujours combattu
les alliances avec le front national et
que je les combattre est toujours et
enfin qu'à titre personnel
jamais je ne voterai pour un candidat du
front national mais tous les doutes sont
ils élevés
tout part de cette déclaration il y a
dix jours la question posée est simple
que faire aux prochaines élections
municipales en cas de duel ps fn
si jamais ce genre de situation se
produit je dis à mes amis
choisissez-le - secteur aps le plus
sectaire qu'un front national ça peut
arriver
autrement dit une brèche est ouverte en
faveur d'un candidat du front national
françois fillon franchit la ligne rouge
jean pierre raffarin menaces de quitter
l'ump
incompréhension de xavier bertrand bruno
le maire ou encore alain juppé sur son
blog il refuse de croire à un calcul
politique pour un repositionnement
tactique avec en ligne de mire les
primaires en 2016 à l'arrivée un
consensus est adopté à l'unanimité une
nouvelle consigne qui plaît à tout le
monde contre les socialistes
les extrémistes et les sectarismes on
passe d'une ineo contre contre et donc
les choses ne changent pas sur le fond
en réalité c'est une évolution
sémantique sur une position qui n'a pas
changé une ligne officielle
presqu'identique et surtout l'apaisement
pas question de réveiller la guerre des
chefs à quelques mois des élections
municipales où selon un dernier sondage
plus d'un sympathisant ump sur deux
souhaite des alliances avec le front
national
alors on en parle avec vous valérie
pécresse n'est d'abord un éclairage on
retrouve notre éditorialiste des
gendarmes bonjour alors françois fillon
et jean-françois copé ont calmé le jeu
mais tout n'est pas forcément réglé est
ce qu'aujourd'hui l'ump est menacée
d'implosion
oui c'est le discours dominant des
commentateurs l'ump va exploser moi je
n'y crois pas du tout
deux savaient de rang passé on a souvent
annoncé l'explosion des grands partis le
ps combien de fois on nous le raconter
ça ne s'est jamais produit pourquoi je
n'y crois pas parce que je pense que les
intérêts qui unissent les gens de l'ump
sont supérieurs aux inconvénients qui
subirait en se séparant et notamment
aujourd'hui je crois que la contrainte
de l'agenda électoral qui fait que c'est
impossible que l'ump se divise elle vit
sous la contrainte d'un calendrier qui a
d'ailleurs été très largement accéléré
par lé quinquennat moi je crois qu'on ne
se rend pas compte qu'on ne mesure pas
très bien à quel point le quinquennat à
modifier les rythmes politiques et les
contraintes et les contraintes
politiques
si l'ump avait dû exploser et c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs se recomposer c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs une occasion ratée
je sais que des amis de françois fillon
quelques-uns le pousser à sortir du
parti au moment où il ya le conflit avec
jean françois copé
mais ça aurait dû se faire dans le
souffle de l'élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui tous ces refuges et et je
pense que les intérêts bien compris
électoraux de chacun et les calculs de
chacun les oblige à rester ensemble
valérie pécresse là un petit mot comme
sur l'analyse est clair qu'on va revenir
sur le fond de cette affaire
ah mais moi je pense que l'ump a rétabli
vraiment une position unanime
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est
complètement rassembler et qui a aucun
risque d'implosion en revanche le revenu
dit et je pense qu'on peut dire quand
même que c'est uniquement pour qu'elle
le feu halte au feu non vous pouvez pas
dire ça le communiqué commencé notre
ligne politique l'ump moi je suis
partisane que l'ump aujourd'hui tranche
les questions on a un comité politique
qui se réunit tous les mardis avec tous
les ténors du parti toutes les
sensibilités du parti
je pense qu'il faut que tous les mardis
on évoque les grands sujets les
retraites les impôts la ligne face au fn
et je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait une
ligne politique déterminée dans ce cadre
du sous comité politique parce que
effectivement ce qui nous unit est plus
fort que ce qui nous divise mais comme
on a un problème de leadership et des
voix qui s'expriment qu'il ya un
problème de leadership au sein du parti
tant qu'on n'a pas désigné être candidat
à la présidentielle
donc tant qu'on n'a pas désigné ce
candidat eh bien je pense que les voix
s'exprimant il faut qu'on ait une ligne
politique commune et on l'a sur le fn
et j'en suis très sale à droite
décomplexée
pour françois fillon qui prend goût
visiblement mais enfin je dire moi je
comprends pas cette expression je dire
moi je ne sais pas mais on a tous aucun
complexe
on a tous des propositions à faire le
problème c'est d'après d'en débattre
est ce que à l'ump on est pour le fait
que les salaires nets doivent augmenter
est ce qu'on y pour la réforme du
financement de la protection sociale
parce qu'on est pas mal
est-ce qu'on est pour une règle d'or de
stabilité fiscale pendant cinq ans est
ce que on est pour des alliances et de
vote contre le front national
on a réaffirmé qu ont été conviés les
socialistes et contre les voulu
réaffirmer mais 50% des militants ump
eux sont prêts à des alliances pour les
municipales qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez à mes militants
je leur réponds plusieurs choses d'abord
c'est pas nouveau en 97 98 quand je me
suis engagé en politique au moment des
régionales ce débat avait déjà lieu et
les proportions étaient peu ou prou
similaire le problème des militants ceux
qui veulent gagner ils pensent que
françois hollande emmène le pays dans le
mur
bon aujourd'hui je leur réponds que nous
allons nous adresser aux électeurs du
front national
nous les ostraciser rompt pas nous ne
les oublierons pas mais simplement que
c'est nous qui avons les solutions et si
j'ai passé neuf mois à écrire un certain
nombre d'idées c'est parce que je pense
qu'une c'est nous qui avons les
solutions la fermeture des frontières la
sortie d'euros c'est pas des solutions
les solutions elles sont dans des vraies
réformes de la justice de la sécurité de
l'immigration mais des vraies réformes
vénéjan gard oui je réagis sur votre
formule une position unanime peut-être
sur le front national mais vous n'avez
pas une position unanime est d'ailleurs
votre discours est contradictoire il
faut qu'on n'est pas donc vous n'avez
pas de position unanime et je pense que
lui a fait un livre sous tension et ne
faisant pas vivre autrement que sous
tension tant qu'elle aura en effet pas
réglé son problème de livres d'art
chiffre à travers les primaires
moi je crois que on va pas pétrifié
l'ump pendant deux ans je crois que 2013
2014 c'est le moment du débat d'idées à
l'ump on peut assumer ne pas être
d'accord
là par exemple d'un exemple convention
éducation certains à l'ump propose un
examen d'entrée en 6ème et si les
enfants rate l'examen il reste en cm2 et
rentre pas au collège
moi je pense que ça ne marche pas je
pense qu'il faut effectivement évaluer
le niveau des enfants à la sortie du
primaire
mais qu'il faut mais qu'il faut au
contraire que le collège s'organisent
pour accueillir de manière totalement
différencier les enfants selon leur
niveau mais je pense qu'on veut pas
laisser les adolescents dans le primaire
vous voyez qu'on a du débat à l'ump s'en
prend encore faut-il que ce débat soit
organisé quand on interroge des cadres
de l'ump ils disent que l'ump
aujourd'hui ne fonctionne pas qu'il n'y
a pas de véritable tête à la direction
de l'ump est au fond en vain le
sentiment qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus une
étiquette comme parti c'est monsieur
jean bart l'autoflagellation c'est le
mal le plus répandu en france ça ne vaut
pas que à l'intérieur de l'ump les
sabots aussi dans la vie des hommes
politiques non mais attendez moi je le
dis très clairement nous avons un sujet
sur le leadership qui sera tranché le
moment venu mais comme il sera tranché
le moment venu qu'est ce que nous devons
faire nous les cadres à de l'ump on doit
travailler sur la ligne politique pour
infléchir y est vous avez très bien dit
que le quinquennat changé beaucoup la
nature des choses pour un parti
politique
quels rôles d'un parti politique quand
on sait bien que c'est l'élection
présidentielle qui commande tout est ce
qu'on se dit finalement ça sert pas à
grand chose c'est juste pour organiser
la campagne ou est ce que c'est le lieu
où se définit la ligne ont pour moi
c'est le lieu où se définit l'avait dit
tout à l'heure les primaires évidemment
et une autre personnalité qui a fait son
retour encore une fois cette semaine
celle de nicolas sarkozy vous avez
peut-être vu cette petite phrase qu'un
peu qui a fait le tour un petit peu un
peu partout les médias la petite actu
politique
je n'en peux plus je ne peux plus pour
m'aider la france c'est autre chose
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
en tout cas à la place qui est la mienne
ce que je veux c'est infléchir le débat
d'idées les propositions pour la france
du futur candidat
je demande si parce que je dis quel que
soit le candidat de l'ump en 2017 moi ce
que je souhaite c'est qu'il reprenne mes
idées voilà et je pense que mon rôle je
pense que mon rôle en tant que cadre à
génère pardon reparler un tout petit peu
de moi mais je pense que mon rôle en
tant qu' en tant qu' en tant que cadre à
génère ayant 5 ans d'expérience
ministérielle et 15 ans d'expérience
politique
c'est d'apporter ma pierre au débat y
est et de ne plus me faire imposer un
programme par un leader qui n'auraient
pas concertés sont profondes et gérard
fillon est toujours au fond votre favori
pour la primaire est l'homme que vous
souhaitez soutenir
y compris en essayant de d'apporter
votre contribution à son programme n'est
sûr moi je partage le diagnostic de
françois fillon sur l'état de la france
et je pense que la france a besoin d'un
réformateur serein comme vous n'avez pas
été ébranlée par la question sur le sur
le front national et je lui répétais je
l'aurais été l'enjeu leur a été si
françois fillon n'avait pas
immédiatement rectifié je lui ai posé la
question dès qu'on est sorti de
l'émission sur europe 1 merci denis
jeambar pour cet éclairage on reprend
tout de suite le cours de la semaine
avec mardi une grande avancée au sénat
la parité hommes femmes adoptée en
première lecture par les sénateurs un
projet de loi très symbolique est une
mesure phare la réforme du congé
parental
nathalie gouard à la maison au travail
la loi parité femmes hommes veut toucher
tous les domaines
l'une des mesures phare la réforme du
congé parental
il s'agit d'inciter les pères en prendre
une partie à partir du 1er juillet 2014
les parents d'un seul enfant qui ont
aujourd'hui droit à six mois de congé
pourront par exemple prendre six mois de
plus à une condition que le congé soit
partagée entre les deux parents avec ces
modifications le gouvernement souhaite
que le nombre d'hommes en congé parental
passe de 18 mille actuellement à 100
milles d'ici la fin du quinquennat
le projet de loi vise également à
protéger les femmes victimes de
violences en privilégiant l'éviction du
conjoint violent du domicile du couple
la justice pourra le condamner à suivre
à ses frais un stage de sensibilisation
en plus des peines prononcées
autre disposition celle d'une garantie
contre les impayés de pension
alimentaire
par ce mécanisme les caisses
d'allocations familiales pourront
effectuer des saisies sur les
prestations familiales des mauvais
payeurs
le but aider les mères isolées on estime
que 40% de ces pensions ne sont pas
versées ou ne le sont que partiellement
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
projet de loi égalité hommes femmes et
notamment aussi
deux des nouvelles mesures qui sont
prises pour éviter de sexiste puisque
vous personnellement dans votre vie
politique vous avez souffert du sexisme
à de nombreuses reprises
d'ailleurs si je suis en politique c'est
en réalité parce que quand j'étais
enceinte de mon premier enfant
on m'a refusé un travail qui me
passionnait dans un domaine qui me
passionnait le cinéma et mais comme je
n'ai pas pu avoir ce travail je suis
resté au conseil d'état et après je me
suis engagé en politique c'est grâce non
je sais pas d'actrice mais c'était au
centre national de la cinématographie
très exactement donc vous voyez que une
une décision sexistes bond m'a permis
discriminatoire m'a permis aux journées
des transpositions ce texte parce que ça
change radicalement la donne pour les
femmes ou ben non alors moi je pense
deux choses d'abord il ya un certain
nombre de dispositions qui existent déjà
peu ou prou si on améliore le dispositif
sur les femmes battues
c'était moi qui avait fait voter la
première mesure justement d'exclusion
des conjoint violent du domicile
il ya quelques années dans la loi
divorce donc je pense que ces mesures
sont bonnes je pense que il faut aller
vraiment très loin sur le recouvrement
des pensions alimentaires des femmes
divorcées je l'espère que la loi
améliorera la situation même si je crois
que tous ces dispositifs existent déjà
mais moi il ya une disposition de la loi
qui me tracasse c'est celle sur le congé
parental parce que je pense qu'en
réalité
najat vallaud-belkacem najat vallaud
belkacem s'est fait un peu avoir par
bercy bercy rêve depuis toujours de
rogner les avantages du congé parental
est là en donnant six mois en réduisant
de six mois le congé parental et en
obligeant les pères à prendre les six
derniers mois
on risque de plonger les familles dans
des situations extrêmement délicate
parce que si le père louis x ou y
non sur le new louis au niveau financier
au niveau des modes de garde
si oui vous imaginez une mère qui a pris
deux ans et demi de congé parental
on lui dit 'maintenant ça s'arrête il
faut que ce soit le père qui prennent le
relais mais l'enfant est accueilli à
l'école qu'à trois ans donc il y aura
six mois de carême de garde
le caractère obligatoire pour moi est
dangereux et risquent de plonger un
certain nombre de femmes dans des
situations où deux familles dans des
situations extrêmement difficiles vous
auriez propose de quoi faut à la place
alors moi je pense que c'est pas mal de
mettre une obligation symbolique pour
les pères de prendre un peu trop g mais
le problème c'est qu'en réalité si on
veut
vraiment impliquer les pères dans
l'éducation des enfants je crois qu'il
faudrait aller vers une autre mesure qui
est celle d'un congé de solidarité
familiale qu'ils puissent être pris par
les deux parents six mois pour chaque
parent et qui inciterait évidemment les
pères à prendre leur congé sur tout a
duré dix l'enfant valérie pécresse dans
votre vie vous en fait état aussi on va
parler des retraites qui savait attaques
du pouvoir des mots des personnes plus
âgées pardon la solidarité familiale ça
peut aussi être beau des personnes âgées
en parler de retraite un allongement de
la durée de cotisation à 43 ans en 2035
des mesures pour la prévention de la
pénibilité pour les femmes le projet de
loi est vivement critiquée bien sûr par
la droite et le cendrier benameur juste
et équilibrée à la sortie du conseil des
ministres marisol touraine assure que la
réforme permettra de sauver le système
des retraites
c'est une réforme de progrès une réforme
d'avenir qui n'occulte pas les défis
financiers à relever mais indique que
ces défis doivent être relevés de
manière différente selon les carrières
professionnelles
le gouvernement choisit de ne pas
toucher à l'âge légal fixé à 62 ans
depuis 2010 en revanche il poursuit
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
en 2035 43 ans seront nécessaires pour
toucher une pension à taux plein la
réforme prévoit aussi une hausse des
cotisations vieillesse pour les salariés
le patronat hausse qui devrait atteindre
0 3 % en 2017
en contrepartie le gouvernement met
l'accent sur la création d'un compte
temps pénibilité il permettra aux
salariés exerçant des métiers difficiles
de partir plus tôt à la retraite tous de
se reconvertir
mais l'opposition dénonce une réforme a
minima et bien sûr la convergence
public-privé lors qu'on pouvait
s'attendre à une évolution significative
rien sur les régimes spéciaux et on peut
dire qu'effectivement cette inégalité
est bien perdue
la réforme pourrait aussi considérer
d'une certaine manière un peu hypocrite
puisque elle choisit le relèvement de la
durée de cotisation plutôt que le report
de l'âge légal
selon plusieurs sondages huit français
sur dix ne croit pas à cette réforme si
elle ne suscite pas autant de grogne que
celle de 2010
la mobilisation n'est pas fini pour
autant
la cgt annonce des actions du 7 au 11
octobre au moment même où les
parlementaires examineront la loi dans
l'hémicycle
valérie pécresse on pourrait se demander
pourquoi est ce que pour une fois sur ce
thème
il ne pourrait pas y avoir une forme
d'union sacrée entre la droite et la
gauche les retraites ça concerne tout le
monde
vous avez raison à condition qu'ils
aient une réforme sur la table
aujourd'hui une réforme ne s'est pas une
réforme c'est une hausse d'impôts on va
augmenter les cotisations des salariés
et augmenter les cotisations des
employés une réforme mais enfin c'est
pas une réforme c'est une hausse d'impôt
une hausse d'impôt qui va baisser le
pouvoir d'achat est baissée et et rendre
l'emploi plus cher donc qu'il va créer
du chômage
donc je suis désolé mais c'est la
mauvaise solution il fallait travailler
si on aurait pu travailler ensemble sur
le report de l'âge légal sur
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
on est plutôt d'accord mais sauf qu'en
faisant l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation et pas le report de l'âge
légal le gouvernement choisit il fait
peser tout l'effort sur la génération
des moins de 40 ans qu'elle la bonne
mesure alors apprendre plus mais je
crois qu'il faut il faut enfin nous nous
avions une position que nous avons une
position très claire c'est lui baisse
des retraites ni hausse des cotisations
ni l'un ni l'autre
on travaille davantage est évidemment
dans ces cadres là on peut envisager la
création d'un fonds pénibilité mais pas
de fond pénibilité si on n'a pas assumé
le report de l'âge légal
il n'y a rien qui trouve grâce à vos
yeux dans cette réforme il n'y a pas si
notamment sur la pénibilité
celle ci mais je vous le dis mais le
problème du fonds de pénibilité c'est
que il doit accompagner un site un
donnant-donnant le fond pénibilité si on
devait exister n'est pas d'accord si on
donne un avantage supplémentaire aux
salariés parce qu'ils ont eu des métiers
pénibles
il faut en même temps que l'on soit
cohérent qu'on leur dise qu'il faudra
travailler un petit peu plus longtemps
toutes les façons qu'on le sait bien on
regarde l'allongement de la durée de la
vie cette réforme elle ne permet que de
couvrir un tiers du chemin qu'il faut
faire d'ici 2020 et j'ajoute qu'elle est
injuste puisque donc il y aura guère
rapprochement le pouvoir aux demies
17 est ce qu'il y aura une nouvelle
réforme des retraites mais il y aura
vraisemblablement un trou que nous aura
laissé dans le financement nouveau
réforme il y aura vraisemblablement un
trou le bouclage financier de cette
réforme n'est pas assurée ce n'est pas
une réforme c'est une hausse d'impôt et
nous on n'augmentera pas les impôts en
2010 et vous toucheriez aux régimes
spéciaux qui est quand même l'un des
problèmes et il faudrait accélérer la
réforme que nous avons mises en oeuvre
en 2010 et effectivement il faut aller
plus loin et plus vite dans la
convergence des régimes publics privés
s'ils ont les français jugeront sa
extraordinairement injustes que les
augmentations de cotisations touche
essentiellement des salariés du privé
valérie pécresse s'était aussi l'heure
de vérité pour la mesure phare du
gouvernement hollande les députés ont
fait un premier bilan des emplois et des
verdicts pas si mal mais a amélioré
après la mise en place d emplois
d'avenir laisser députés en charge de
l'évaluation du dispositif rendre leur
copie
150 pages pour un bilan positif même si
quelques ajustements sont évoqués
il n'y a pas d'égalité dans les
territoires quand vous habitez en ville
quand vous habitez en zone urbaine
sensible il ya moins d'emplois qui sont
créées simplement parce que dans ces
territoires là il ya moins d'emplois et
donc par exemple je propose que ce qu'on
appelle les grands comptes c'est-à-dire
la poste la sncf la ratp les hôpitaux
baïse ans il offre plus d'emplois dans
ces territoires là qu'ailleurs pour
compenser le fait qu'il y ait plus de
difficultés ces emplois d'avenir sont
destinés aux jeunes de 16 à 25 ans peu
ou pas qualifiés qui résident dans d
autres marquée par le chômage par ce
dispositif les employeurs s'engagent à
embaucher des jades en cdi ou en cdd et
en contrepartie ils reçoivent une aide
financière de l'état 75 % du salaire et
des charges sociales sont payés par le
gouvernement
cinquante six mille contrats ont été
signés en huit mois l'état prévoit d'en
signer cent mille d'ici la fin de
l'année
pour l'opposition ce coup d'accélérateur
est motivé par une stratégie politique
de françois hollande
ces emplois d'avenir qui ne sont pas un
dispositif génial d'ailleurs ont été
retenus restreint pour assurer le
maximum dans fallait tenir
en fin d'année pour permettre à françois
hollande de tenir son engagement d'un
version totalement artificielle la
courbe de chômage en fin d'année les
contrats d'avenir vont coûter deux
milliards d'euros pour l'année 2013
l'état a pour objectif d'enseigner 150
milles d'ici 2014
quand la droite était au pouvoir elle a
eu aussi recours à ce type d'instrument
ce type d'emploi finalement c'est pas
une si mauvaise mesure que ça on va dire
la vérité
l'économie française est très malade
elle souffre d'un grave problème de
compétitivité
les emplois aidés c'est de l'aspirine
c'est un anti douleur ça ne guérira pas
l'économie française ce qui guérira
l'économie française c'est une politique
de compétitivité et de ce point de vue
est bien le gouvernement a les mots de
la compétitivité mais absolument pas les
actes quand on fait une réforme des
retraites on augmente les cotisations
pour renchérir le coût du travail on
détricote complètement la compétitivité
quand on annonce un crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi et qu'on enlève 13
milliards 6 d'allègement de tva de
charges sociales la tva sociale
on enlève les 13 milliards 6 pour mettre
un crédit d'impôt qui n'entrera en
vigueur qu'en 2014 et qui pour l'instant
ne touche personne vous voyez bien qu'on
va contre la compétitivité la création
d'emplois marchands les d'emplois dans
l'économie réelle mais mais mais ces
jeunes concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire d'autre aussi pour les aider le
choix de jeunes c'est un fléau qui
touche d'ailleurs plusieurs pays
d'europe certains ont réussi à mettre au
point des mesures qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire mais je vais vous donner un
exemple l'apprentissage
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui pour
financer les emplois d'avenir les
régions prennent les crédits d'aidé à
l'apprentissage en ile-de-france 13
millions d'euros d'argent donnée par le
gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy à la
région pour augmenter l'apprentissage
qui sont pris pour aller faire des
emplois dernière est ce que vous croyez
vraiment que l'avenir des jeunes c'est
dans des contrats de un an de 2 ans dans
le secteur public
ces contrats vont s'arrêter un jour est
ce que vous croyez pas que l'avenir des
jeunes
elle est dans l'apprentissage en
entreprise avec un vrai le pied une
vraie qualification aux grosses dit la
vérité
vous seriez aujourd'hui président de la
région ile de france
je crois que vous aimeriez avoir en tout
cas pour 2015 vous embauche auriez des
emplois d'avenir ou pas mais je ne
nierai certainement pas prendre les
crédits de l'apprentissage pour lui
mettre sur les emplois d'avenir mais on
peut embaucher des emplois d'avenir mais
ça ne peut pas je vous dis c'est là
spearing oui à de l'aspirine pour les
mots d'urgence les paye nos taux de
chômage mais le sujet mais pas
d'instrument sujet c'est la création
d'emplois marchands dans les dix ans qui
viennent si je voulais donner un avenir
à vos enfants
il faut que les entreprises continuent
d'investir en france de créer de
l'emploi dans un monde où étaient aussi
ceux qui n'ont pas forcément si j'étais
président de la région ile de france je
créerai je créerai des aides
supplémentaires pour l'apprentissage
je soutiendrai les pme en difficulté je
mettrai le développement économique
comme une priorité on est la dernière
région de france quasiment son
développement économique
est ce que croyait que tout ça est
sérieux on va parler d'autre chose
valérie pécresse on va aller au sénat
cette fois bel sénateur se rebiffe côté
là le texte sur le non cumul des mandats
a été adopté mais largement amendé
puisque les sénateurs ont fait voter des
abonnements qui leur permettent une
forme d'exception pour eux mêmes comptes
rendus de séance pour le mois épique
avec fera sauvage
23 35 le sénat passe à l'attaqué nous en
venons par conséquent à 3 amendement
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
les sénateurs examinent l'amendement des
radicaux de gauche
objectif maintenir la possibilité de
cumuler un mandat de parlementaire avec
un mandat local li nord-est la nécessité
de dire par un amendement disant une
chose claire simple qui n'est aucunement
excessive de dire que tout sénateur aura
la possibilité de conserver un mandat
exécutif que ce local que ce soit maires
ou présidents d'intercommunalités ou
président d'un acte exécutif
départemental ou régional adopté par 211
voix contre 83 c'est un baroud d'honneur
pour le gouvernement au sein du groupe
socialiste 25 sénateurs ont voté contre
l'avis du gouvernement face à cette
opposition le ministre de l'intérieur
manuel valls a choisi la fermeté savez
le le sénat dans les années 20 dans les
années 30 avait refusé ce que
l'assemblée nationale proposait à
l'époque le droit de vote pour les
femmes
le sénat a refusé il y a
quelques semaines le scrutin binominal
qui instaure pour les élections au
départemental la parité absolue rentrer
dans les faits puisque l'assemblée
nationale la beauté parfois le sénat qui
est une chambre qui travaille très bien
avec des rapports des textes de lois des
débats qui sont intéressants et
passionnant oubli qui a des mouvements
dans la société
dans les rangs de l'ump on se félicite
de l' échec du gouvernement
mais on n'apprécie guère le style de
manuel valls la méthode liste et le ton
qui l'employait particulièrement
agressif j'allais dire menaçant est
absolument intolérable
nous ne céderons pas aux pressions et je
pense que le match n'est pas terminé
il ya d'abord le vote à l'assemblée
nationale on peut imaginer qu'il soit
sûr et puis il ya le recours au conseil
constitutionnel
en attendant le sénat doit voter le
projet de loi d'ici à vendredi avant que
l'assemblée nationale ait le dernier mot
justement la sûreté nationale qui a le
dernier mot un risque évidemment de
refaire basculer tout ce qui a été voté
au sénat où vous êtes pour vous êtes
content qu est ce que vous allez voter
voilà semblait alors moi je suis à titre
personnel contre le cumul des mandats
mais je suis aussi contre la loi et je
m'en explique
on aujourd'hui les parlementaires sont
des nains politiques
institutionnellement depuis toujours
c'est-à-dire qu'un parlementaire et vous
le savez ici llcp mieux que quiconque
c'est une secrétaire un collaborateur un
petit bureau une petite permanence pas
de budget pas de pad équipe
rien aucun moyen de contrôler
gouvernement aucun moyen de réaliser un
vrai projet de loi surtout quand on est
dans l'opposition et qu'on utilise la la
la la force des commissions et face au
ministre on est évidemment vraiment tout
petit donc je comprends de ce point de
vue la fronde des sénateurs qui exprime
cet attachement au cumul qui leur permet
en réalité de faire de la politique
correctement
donc aujourd'hui il faut que le
gouvernement aille jusqu'au bout de sa
logique s'il veut le non cumul
il faut faire un vrai statut du
parlementaire peut être divisé par deux
c'est ce que je propose
diviser par deux le nombre des
parlementaires mais leur donner des
vrais et aux etats-unis en allemagne
un parlementaire qui sait faire une loi
il peut contrôler un ministre il peut
vraiment j'allais dire exercé un vrai
pouvoir démocratique il est un
antoine dit non la loi telle qu'elle a
été votée au sénat qui permet cet
amendement pour garder le cumul déborda
vous voterez oui vous votre et non à
l'assemblée
non mais moi je votre que je voterai
contre le texte mais je ne sais pas mais
je ne suis pas favorable au cumul
on a en tout cas deux visions de la
république qui s'affrontent avec d'un
côté un peu les chevronnés du terrain et
de l'autre plus les experts pour vous
qui a le plus de légitimité
mais aujourd'hui quelle est la logique
de françois hollande on la voit très
bien c'est de faire de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat
des lieux où on ne retrouvera plus que
des apparatchiks politique vous enlevez
le cumul donc plus d'ancrage territorial
vous rajoutez la proportionnelle donc
des scrutins de liste avec des listes
faites par les partis politiques
vous n'aurez plus à l'assemblée que des
apparatchiks qui n'auront jamais vu la
vraie vie et bien moi je refuse ce
système
je pense que les députés doivent avoir
un ancrage territorial mais avoir une
vraie qui leur permettent face à des
barons locaux des grands mères des
présidents de conseil général les
présidents de conseils régionaux de
pouvoir dire des choses fortes et agir
qu'est ce qui vous choque le plus au
cumul des mandats ou le cumul des
indemnités que c'est quoi la vraie
question
mais ça n'a rien c'est ni le cumul des
mandats ni le cumul des indemnités le
sujet c'est comment est ce qu un député
ou un sénateur peut faire la loi et
contre les gouvernements quels moyens
vous lui donnez vous lui donnez quoi une
1/2 car de bureaux même pas un
abonnement à la presse 7000 euros de
crédit pour payer des collaborateurs en
ile de france ça veut dire quoi
en allemagne on a combien de
collaborateurs quand on débute et
combien on a deux collaborateurs quand
on est député aux états unis deux mois
de problèmes - deux ministres aussi et
plus de charges pour les parlementaires
non mais moi vous savez vu que la
proposition moi je différentes seront
supprimés secrétaire d'état et qu'on ait
des députés secrétaire d'état qu'ils
soient membres du parlement et qu'on
économistes tous les frais de
secrétariat d'état je propose qu'on
divise par deux le nombre de ministres
ces coquilles remaniement chaque fois
qu'il ya nouveau gouvernement dise oui
on va faire un gouvernement resserré 15
listes on voit que c'est jamais possible
oui ça n'est pas possible parce qu'on a
besoin de trois choses pour la ministre
a besoin de trois choses aller à
bruxelles
aller au parlement est allé en province
donc ça veut dire quoi c'est la cas
ministre si vous voulez que quinze
ministres vous devez avoir ces députés
secrétaire d'état qui vous permettront
de ne pas avoir d secrétariat d'état des
sous-ministres mais d'avoir enrayé
vraiment avec le parlement on parle d'un
autre sujet au coeur de votre livre
l'impôt avec ce couac au niveau sauver
de l'état françois hollande qui promet
une pause fiscale dès 2014 et trois
jours plus tard jean marc ayrault qui
affirme que la pause n'aura lieu qu'en
écoutez d'abord ce qu'on pense ce derner
cazeneuve le ministre du budget je suis
ministre du budget je suis pas ministre
des approximations
donc je veux donner des informations
justes il y a ceux qui informent et ceux
qui font peur le chiffre de 2013 nous
louerons dans quelques jours nous le
rendrons public et je peux d'ores et
déjà vous dire qu'il n'a rien à voir
avec le chiffre qui a été diffusée alors
depuis plusieurs jours la droite et la
gauche se renvoient aussi la
responsabilité de l'augmentation des des
impôts est ce que vous vous regrettez le
gel du bara du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu que vous attendez attendez soyons
très clairs c'est pas le gel du barème
qui fait qu'il ya un million deux cent
mille français de plus imposé cette
année c'est la refiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires et la baisse du
quotient familial nous ensemble
non mais attendez je répond tout à fait
à votre question nous nous avons fait
voter en 2011 pour 2012
la première année de gel du barème nous
avions calculé qu'il y aurait trois cent
mille français de plus de dents et donc
qu'est ce que nous avons fait voter une
décote un mécanisme qui fait que dans la
première tranche vous ne payez pas
d'impôts si vous rentrez dans l'impôt
donc nous avions prévu nous l'avons nous
avions évité
qu'est ce qui se passe la gauche arrive
en juin 2012 et qu'est ce qu'elle décide
de maintenir ce gel du barème mais de
refiscalisation supplémentaires et là
tout explose parce que voyez bien que
des salariés très modeste qui font des
heures supplémentaires se sont retrouvés
du coup dans le barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est ça qui a fait exploser le
système et la gauche a maintenu le gel
du barème la deuxième année donc qu'ils
ne viennent pas nous expliquer qu'on est
encore responsable de leurs turpitudes
la suppression d'une niche fiscale est
ce que pour vous c'est une hausse
d'impôts pas les niches fiscales peuvent
pas être globalisé il ya des systèmes
qui sont qui sont très intéressants pour
créer de l'emploi je vous donne un
exemple les emplois à domicile nous
avons une très fausse vision de la de la
défiscalisation des
emploi à domicile aujourd'hui le
gouvernement on a une très forte vision
pourquoi parce que si vous êtes un chef
d'entreprise et que vous employez un
salarié tout son salaire et ses charges
seront en baisse de votre chiffre
d'affaires quand vous êtes patron d'un
salarié qui vient à domicile ou d'un
employé de services à la personne
vous devriez pouvoir défiscaliser
l'intégralité de son salaire et ses
charges c'est évidemment parce qu'il
fait aujourd'hui on va parler aussi de
fiscalité écologique vendredi on passe
au vert françois hollande a ouvert la
seconde conférence environnementale du
quinquennal va durer deux jours quatorze
ministres présents au menu la politique
de l'eau la biodiversité l'éducation il
évoque aussi la transition écologique
écouter le chef de l'état la transition
énergétique n'est pas un choix de
circonstance n'est pas un compromis
n'est pas une négociation
la transition énergétique c'est une
décision stratégique
ce n'est pas un problème c'est la
solution
si nous n'agissons pas la planète
connaîtra avant la fin du siècle
un réchauffement climatique supérieures
à 3 degrés voire à 4 degrés ce qu'il ya
urgence et ce que l'heure est venue de
faire la transition énergétique mais
vous moi j'aimerais savoir ce qu'on
parle parce que d'abord j'ai le
sentiment que cette conférence
environnemental va surtout se
transformer en conférence fiscale et
qu'à la fin on aura encore des hausses
d'impôts donc mais l'écologie sur des
choses plus d'impôts c'est pas plus
d'écolo je suis désolé c'est pas comme
ça que ça marche
en revanche si vous parlez d'énergie moi
je vous dit deux choses je vous dis que
aujourd'hui il ya trois défis à remplir
le défi de la protection de
l'environnement mais aussi le défi de
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
et le défi est le défi du pouvoir
d'achat de l'énergie pas cher donc
cesser 3d fit faut résoudre ensemble
donc on ne peut pas séparer la question
environnementale de la question de
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
et de la question du pouvoir d'achat ce
qui pose le bilan du nucléaire par
exemple où le bilan du gaz de schiste à
aller étudier et pas
d'année par avance ou voyez ce que je
veux dire vous avez essayé de réformer
la fiscalité écologique de prendre
certaines mesures pourquoi ça n'a pas
marché la taxe carbone par exemple la
taxe carbone a été censurée vous le
savez par le conseil constitutionnel
moi je pense que on peut qu est-ce que
c'est l'impôt l'impôt c'est simple c'est
un instrument pour changer les
comportements
mais il faut faire très attention je
prends l'exemple de la fiscalité diesel
vous moi je propose une règle d'or
fiscale qui consiste à ne pas changer un
impôt plus d'une fois en cinq ans et
surtout à ce qu'il ait pas d'effet
rétroactif c'est à dire que si vous avez
pris une décision avec un impôt on
puisse pas changer changer les règles du
jeu
le diesel c'est un bon exemple on a
poussé les français à acquérir des
diesel parce que c'était moins cher le
carburant le gas-oil et maintenant on
change les règles du jeu moi je pense
qu'il faudrait un temps de latence un an
deux ans avant de changer les règles du
jeu pour que les français puissent
changer voitures écrasées mais le cinéma
les séries ça mais tout ça ah je suis
cinévores rubrique cette année d'un
parlement hebdo
il s'appelle le plus de l'hebdo et on va
s'intéresser justement à ce phénomène
des séries qui envahissent le petit
écran je propose de regarder ce petit
jingle on va voir le sujet juste après
cette série s'appelle house of cards
elle nous vient des états unis elle est
diffusée en ce moment sur canal plus et
elle dévoile et bien la politique
américaine et surtout le dessous de
pouvoir simon barbarie nous explique
tout ça il fixe la caméra avec le
sourire en coin de celui qui en a vu
d'autres
manipulateur machiavélique et cynique et
pourtant presque sympathique
kevin speccy est le héros de la nouvelle
série américaine très politique aux
sauvegardes tout politicien qui
recueillent 70 millions de votes touche
à quelque chose de plus grand que sa
personne de plus grand que moi même si
ça me fait mal de l'admettre
regardez ce sourire de vainqueur se
regarde
j'en ai très tôt fait mon poulain et
j'ai su me rendre indispensable après 25
ans au congrès et j'arrive à savoir dans
quel sens souffle de vie l'acteur
oscarisé incarne franck underwood un
représentant démocrate du parlement
américain
pressenti pour devenir le futur
secrétaire d'état l'équivalent de notre
ministre des affaires étrangères le
poste du passe finalement sous le nez
franck en déroute va alors
méthodiquement préparer sa vengeance
ce cas martyrs souhaite plus que tout
cette affaire sur lequel s'empaler alors
vous aiguiser votre épée où l'attendait
juste au bon angle et décompté 3 la
série house of cards nous montre
l'envers du décor de l'exercice du
pouvoir dans les arcanes de la maison
blanche les intérêts personnels passent
avant ceux de la nation et le scénariste
bowie limon lui-même ancien conseiller
politique là sur son histoire colle au
plus près à la réalité
ce temps fort nous avons d'excellentes
relations de travail avec marty enfin
jusqu ici vous avez vu il a son
caractère ban au général j'arrive à
composer avec elle résonnait mais je
vais peut-être pousser trop loin ce qui
m'inquiète parce que les amis sont les
pires ennemis
après avoir vu les premiers épisodes de
la saison 1 on ne peut alors s'empêcher
de paraphraser cette question de
l'acteur kevin spacey préférons nous
avoir des dirigeants honnêtes mais
impuissant ou des hommes et des femmes à
la moralité douteuse mais qui font
bouger les choses
ouais c'est la série du moment vous la
connaissez peut-être j'ai pas
malheureusement eu le temps de la
regarder mais je jeu là je l'achèterai
dès qu'elle sera disponible pour
répondre à la question de kevin space et
mieux vaut-il as qu'il vaut mieux un
dirigeant honnête et impuissants ou un
homme à la moralité douteuse mais kif et
beaucoup chez les choses
je crois que le cynisme n'est pas la
seule le seul moteur de l'engagement
politique je ne le crois pas en revanche
je pense que maintenant on n'a plus le
choix
comme dirait churchill il faut arrêter
de dire qu'on a fait de notre mieux il
faut réussir ce qui est nécessaire donc
il faut faire bouger les choses mais je
ne suis pas favorable à m au pouvoir des
gens à la moralité douteuse pour autant
ça se passe comme ça vraiment dans le
pouvoir vous qui avez connu un petit peu
tout ça à des gens comme kevin ce
policier autre qu'un colon dans ce rôle
mais côté je ne sais pas parce que je
n'ai pas fait exprès non mais le fait
qu' il y ait des rapports de force en
politique cueillait des stratégies en
politique mais y en a dans la vie je
veux dire dans toute organisation
humaine y en a dans des familles dans
l'entreprise
il y en a partout un politique c'est
quand même connu pour être la photo la
politique c'est particulièrement violent
parce que c'est l'accès au pouvoir et
parce que on est particulièrement exposé
les attaques sont particulièrement
violentes et puis elles vous touchent
dans votre intégrité et puis elles se
font surtout à une échelle absolument
mondial aujourd'hui avec les réseaux
sociaux un président des etats-unis qui
dérape un candidat et voilà les
résonances son mondial donc le choc pour
la personne est mondiale donc c'est
évidemment il ya le plus le plus pourri
talent des métiers à côté obscur de
pouvoir ça existe vraiment ou c'est
uniquement dans les films les séries il
ya un côté obscur de chez tout le monde
d'ailleurs que c'est jérôme cahuzac il
est dit merci beaucoup a repris mais
j'espère que ce n'est pas à la générale
tu es chez les politiques merci à mme
pécresse d'avoir été notre invité qui a
tiré sans sommation prochaine la semaine
prochaine très bon type de programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires